- When you're from the hood,
the first thing you're thinking,
what the fuck is wrong
with this white dude?
Why his nuts hanging like that?
(throbbing electronic music)
(audience cheers)
- Thank you, everybody.
So, if you don't know,
here's what the show is.
It's just a bunch
of funny people
telling like 100% true stories.
Ladies and gentlemen, one of
the funniest women I know,
Ms. Pat, everybody.
Keep it going for Ms. Pat.
(audience cheers)
- So I went through the
Welfare to Work program
through Bill Clinton.
And I know most of
y'all don't know
what the fuck the Welfare
to Work program is.
But it came out of your paycheck
and it helped a
bitch out like me.
(audience laughs)
So, on this program
I got my GED,
got off parole and
got my very first job
working at McDonald's.
And I'm doing like most
people do in my neighborhood
when they get they're very
first job working at McDonald's.
I'm stealing $100 a day
out of the register.
(audience laughs)
What's wrong, this
too real for y'all?
So, I steal $100 and
I had just stolen it
and nobody in the McDonald's
but me and the co-worker.
So I ease the shit in my pocket
and I'm just talking
to the co-worker
'cause there ain't
nobody in there
and I see this fucking
black van circle McDonald's.
And you know, when
you're from the hood,
you see a black van circle,
the first thing you out.
That either the police
or somebody about
to shoot your ass.
(audience laughs)
So, the van circled twice
and then this white guy
get out and he come in and
he got this plug in his ear.
And I'm like, holy fuck.
They done caught me stealing.
I'm going back to jail.
Two seconds later
he look around.
He say, it's clear, send him in.
Now, I tell you, this shit
shocked the shit out of me.
In walk President Jimmy Carter.
(light clapping)
I know his face, but
I don't know his name
and now I'm looking at him
because he got his pants
all jacked up and his nut
sack hanging over to the side.
When you from the hood the
first thing you thinking
what the fuck is wrong
with this white dude?
Why're his nuts
hanging like that?
I didn't know his
name, but you know,
I was like, damn,
I think I know him.
So he get to the register
and I went to take his order
and the Secret Service
standing there.
And you know, I'm crazy
at this time in my life.
You know, just doing
drive bys and selling dope
and you know,
robbing white people.
I'm getting my life back
together, white people.
(audience laughs)
Jimmy Carter get to the register
and I do the most
ghetto shit ever.
I look at Jimmy
Carter and I said,
"Nigger, where the
fuck I know you from?"
(audience laughs)
Secret Service
busts out laughing.
(audience laughs)
I'm standing there
with a straight face
'cause this nigger
look familiar to me.
Jimmy Carter turned pink.
He said, "Young
lady, young lady."
I'm like, what the fuck do
you want to eat, nigger.
You know?
(audience laughs)
So, he ordered a
cheeseburger, a side salad
and a water.
By this time the boy
on the grill was like,
"Patricia, that's the President
of the United States."
I turn around with my
ghetto ass and told him,
"Nigger, I told you I know you.
"Your cheeseburger free."
(audience laughs)
Y'all, that's my
Jimmy Carter story.
(audience cheers)
(throbbing electronic music)